معانا من برلين الاستاذ جاسم محمد مدير
المركز الاوروبيه لدراسات مكافحه
الارهاب اهلا بك استاذ جاسم محمد تتوقف
معك عند هذا القرار
الالماني بعد تحفظ طويل اذا تسليم
اوكرانيا دبابات اليو بارد اثنان ما
تقييمكم بدايه
لهذه الخطوه
هذه الخطوه هي تنقل لالمانيا
وتنقل ايضا المانيا ربما في مساء
الدستوريه
وقانونيه في مشاركات همم الجيش الالماني
وكذلك نقل ايضا في شروط صادرات الاسلحه
الالمانيه التي كانت تحضر ان يتم نقلها
الى مناطق النزاع او الصراعات وهذا يعني
بان المانيا اخذت هذا القرار وهي تدرك
جيدا بانها تنخرط في الحرب ربما بشكل
مباشر مع روسيا من خلال حرب اوكرانيا فاذا
هو تغيير النوعي وهنالك ضغوطات هذه ياتي
بسبب ضغوطات داخليه خاصه من الحزب المسيحي
يؤدي نقراطي من الحزب الديمقراطيه الحر
اضافه الى الضغوطات التي جاءت من داخل
الحلفاء مثل بولندا خمسه دول البلقيه
عن الضغوطات الامريكيه وكذلك الاداره
الامريكيه اوتو وسد جسم ما تبعت هكذا خطوه
خصوصا ان الكريم لين استبق هذا القرار
بالتحذيرنا هذا القرار سيؤثر على العلاقات
لا محل الروسيه الالمانيه
غيرت موقفها 180 درجه الحرب وهذا يعني انه
العلاقات الحميمه او الخصوصيه التي كانت
تمنحها روسيا الى المانيا حتى في موضوعات
الاقتصاد وازمه الطاقه وكذلك صادرات الان
كانت ال كانت كانت روسيه تمنح المانيا
الكثير من الخصوصيه لكن اجد انه الان لم
تعد هذه الخصوصيه عند روسيا وجدت انه حتى
الاتصالات الثنائيه التي كان يعقدها او
يتصل المستشار الالماني مع الرئيس بوتن
يبدو انها سوف لا همم تشهد او تلاقي ترحبا
من قبل اكرم من او من قبل الرئيس بوتن
فيجد انه دور المانيا انخرطت في هذه الحرب
لدراسه مكافحه الارهاب شكرا لك